tu participé parce que j'ai été blessé
lors de la soirée des attentats au stade
de france et donc on avocate m'a proposé
au bout d'un moment tu est partie civile
ce que j'ai accepté instantanément
qu'est-ce que ça pour vous ce secteur
alors pour moi personnellement comme je
suis une victime on va appeler que
latéral que je n'ai pas trop de
séquelles ni physique ni psychologique
j'en ai eu entre temps mais aujourd'hui
on peut dire que c'est passé donc je
viens 1 parce que c'est un événement
extra lelong ordinaire qui suit un autre
événement extra loin ordinaire avec six
ans est quasiment six ans dans
l'intervalle et que pendant ces six ans
a été un véritable fil rouge avec
l'avocat les avocats les émissions
les programmes les télés les rencontres
avec d'autres victimes
l'association à laquelle je
une question sur cette soirée du désir
d'un été dans le stade j'ai assisté au
match
j'ai entendu les détonations il se
trouve que moi je suis extrêmement vive
que c'était des attentats de mars frère
regardait la télé sur le canal allemande
et les allemands n'ont pas caché que le
stade était confiné que nous allions
être vous fines est jusqu'à nouvel ordre
et que de ça continuait dans paris
moi je les suis dit tu
j'ai eu confirmation par des militaires
de la légion au civil qui venaient
assister au match oui oui c'est vrai et
donc j'ai fait des provisions de
nourriture parce que je ne sais pas
combien de temps nous on allait nous
enfermer dans le stade et la buvette
était en train de faire mais tout
simplement pour moi tu prévoyante il ça
a été la seconde mi temps là les
téléphones ont commencé à crépiter de
droite et de gauche donc ça c'est
répondu dans le stade et l'ambiance est
tombé progressivement et très lourdement
ce que les gens on regardait à peine le
mcs compris moi évidemment et ensuite
lorsque le match s'est terminé on nous a
canalisé verse 2 ou 3 sorti uniquement
80000 personnes à faire sortir par deux
ou trois sorties au lieu de 40 pour et
dès que je suis sorti du stade il ya eu
un mouvement de panique
quelques airs entendus avril a déclenché
un truc incroyable et j'ai pas eu le
temps de me retourner pour voir pourquoi
il y avait des séries les cavalcades que
j'étais par terre je suis relevé avec
une triple fracture de l'épaule un
traumatisme du genou les lunettes
cassées je me suis retrouvé au poste de
secours du stade de france ils peur
peut-être pas mais j'ai limité mais
fréquentation dans les stades et lors de
l'euro 80
2016 j'ai été une seule fois la fan zone
alors que j'aurais aimé aller plus
souvent et on m'a mise à l'abri parce
que
l'ombre de la croix rouge a compris que
j'avais dit j'ai été victime des
attentats majeurs à je vais vous mettre
là je vais vous protégez vous serez sans
danger voilà et hier soir là j'ai re
router et la boucle est bouclée quelques
paroles volet jeu génial y ont assisté
au match ce france finlande
je ne connaissais pas le nouveau stade
d'une part une ambiance fabuleuse